red mullet with sweet chili sauce
it's about being adventurous and having
the confidence to go off peace and being
a little bit more daring so when you
start combining peanuts chili flakes and
this amazing fish red mullet trust me
you're in for an amazing treat
we're gonna make a really nice light
sweet chili sauce
first off your chili off with the top in
half
on those seeds inside are very powerful
incredibly hot
but full of flavor garlic
two cloves of garlic
slice the garlic nice and thin so it
helps the puree
the chilies in the pasta water garlic in
salt and it will touch
sugar
in
and then start grinding
push down first
[Music]
the salt and the sugar
really helps to puree the chili and the
garlic
fish sauce always a base
to a chili sauce two tablespoons in
a touch of rice wine vinegar
fish sauce gives it the saltiness the
vinegar gives it a nice acidic wake up
three tablespoons
of olive oil
nice
mix that up beautiful look at the colors
incredible now spring onions I want the
texture
and the crunch spring onions in
the coriander slice it once
in fresh lime
and that goes brilliantly with a red
mullet just really wakes up the chili
the garlic and reminds the sauce that
we're serving with fish now taste
look at that
beautiful the longer that chili sauce
sits there the better it gets now for
the peanuts and chili that's going to
coat the top of the red mullet
peanuts in
salt
and that helps to really grind the
peanuts down some beautiful dried chili
flakes creates a nice sort of warm heat
I'm using fresh chili for the sauce but
dried chili flakes for the coating which
will really crunch up when cooking just
a little bit of the coriander
mix the coriander in
to the peanuts and look I like them
quite textured I don't want them too
small as a powder otherwise they'll burn
but crushed lightly to coat the fish
with the chili and peanut seasoning in a
separate Bowl beat two eggs along with a
splash of fish sauce
take your fillet lay in your red money
dip it in shake up your peanuts
and then in and make sure you push that
down cover that red Monet
oh beautiful
now make sure that Pan's really nice I'm
piping hot if you put the fish in and
the Pan's cold
all those wonderful peanuts and chili
just going to slide off the fish so we
need to sear it in and get it nice and
crisp in and lay away from you
peaceful
[Music]
if the pan starts getting a little bit
too hot get your eyeball
and just Place Another teaspoon of olive
oil around the outside so it starts to
heat up as it hits the center and it
really helps to stay so much more in
control
and turn
nice and gently
we want that nice sort of toasted
sauteed crispness
which adds A really lovely flavor
tilt the pan and just baste
the top of the red mullet with a really
nice piping hot olive oil you've got
that really nice roasted Crunch and it
goes brilliantly with that soft
sweetness of that fish inside gas off
and just leave them sitting in there
and finish with lime and just go over
each one
now we'll take them out
and sauce
and the tail of each fish
now to round that off
serving some fragrant rice
sauteed broccoli
amazing and there you have a delicious
peanut encrusted red mullet with a
wonderful sweet chili sauce cooking with
chilies isn't all about blow your head
off heat this dish uses the exciting
Taste of a chili but has a deliciously
elegant and subtle flavor
my next recipe is a proper British
classic that's super simple to cook and
costs next to nothing a delicious apple
crumble
crumbles are the perfect way to use
fruit when it's in season there's lots
of it about it's nice and cheap but most
importantly the fruits at its absolute
best
foreign
make a really nice light caramel pan on
nice and low great two apples
[Music]
and this helps to almost sort of pure
the Apple so much quicker there's a lot
of flavor in the skin so don't worry
about peeling the fruit whether it's
pears plums peaches flavors in the skin
nice to start the camera a couple of
tablespoons of sugar the sugar helps to
get rid of the tartness in the Apple a
touch
Cinema that starts to make it a little
spicy open up your vanilla and just
scrape out all those seeds now this just
makes it light and fragrant all those
seeds in to the Sugar We're making
caramel be patient and always swirl the
dish instead of stirring it
when the sugar goes Brown add the Apple
starts to sort of cool down the caramel
but it gives it a really nice sort of
caramelized puree apples almost
disintegrating
smells incredible turn the gas down
slice up two apples it's a crumble
That's Got No Frills straight forward no
faffing around no peeling on the skin I
want them to sort of stand out from the
camera
apples in
now those nice thick chunks of Apple
sort of almost bedding itself into the
puree
dried cranberries gives it that nice
sort of shock in the texture
sweet
chewy I want it to sort of taste zesty
spicy so sit the lemon zest on top of
your apples and cranberry fresh lemon
juice over and that just gives that
extra acidic kick takes the Cranberries
the apples the caramel and the cinnamon
to another level turn the gas off
that says let's concentrate on the
crumble flowering
a couple of tablespoons of Demerara
sugar sugar helps to get the topping
nice and crispy butter in
give that a nice little rub what we're
looking for is like a
breadcrumb mixture lightly season it
with a touch of cinnamon
and the dinner sugar sort of helps to
get a nice fine crumble mix and it stops
the butter from sort of melting in that
flour so that's the basic crumble mix
but I'm not finished yet muesli
two-thirds crumble
one third muesli mix that in if you
haven't got muesli then crunchy granola
works brilliantly too lovely
now start off in the center
and work your way around
I want the crispiness on the top the
puree on the bottom of the caramel and
then the texture in the center a good
tip
hand the gas back on I want it bubbling
before it goes in the oven because then
you just got to cook the top so as soon
as you see that caramel starting to
Bubble down the side in she goes let's
go
all right
bake it 200 degrees Celsius for 12 to 14
minutes until golden brown
smells amazing
[Music]
still bubbling
and look at it a delicious but very
simple crumble with apples at their
absolute best beautiful
[Music]
foreign